Maureen is with us in Orlando Florida
Marine your question for Rachael and I
about smart money smart kids hi guys is
such a pleasure to talk to you I'm so
excited to be able to get on the on the
radio thank you you too how can we help
Thank You well me and my husband Tom
I've just completed FPU or a baby step 2
right now but we have two children
Washington a children ones 24 ones 18
living at home still so basically my
husband and I are on the plan and we're
working it but the problem that we're
seems to be having is that on we have to
agree like I said grown adults living at
home they only work about 15 to 20 hours
a week they both work part-time that
both going to school as well and they
just recently started paying their own
phone bills but my husband and I pay for
everything else car insurance you name
it we pay it and I'm just trying to
decide what would be a fair amount for
them to start contributing maybe per
week cause I mean we've spoiled them as
well I mean we've made the mistake of
you know trying to give them everything
and then now now my husband I are
smarter now about our money we're trying
to follow the steps and get us ourselves
out of debt you know which one to think
about ourselves as well as far as
retirement and paying off our debt and
our loans and everything um which one to
get them on board both of them are in
school my oldest one is in school my
youngest one is in school as well yes
okay as long as they're in school I'm
fine with that and with you paying parts
of things or giving them a free place to
live that's an incentive and a wonderful
thing and of course as long as they're
behaving that's part of the rent they
pay and that includes living under my
value system since you live under my
freaking roof okay that's how that works
so I don't care how old you are if
you're so old you're cool too cool to
live here then you're too cool live here
head on so but as long as they ours all
went away to college but as long as they
were in school we would have allowed
them to stay in the house that's fine
and and we would have provided heat and
cool and maybe wash their clothes and
certainly have cooked meals and those
kinds of things
cell phones car insurance car gas that
kind of thing I'm going to start moving
that off onto them pretty quick
okay and then pick up a few more hours
of work it won't hurt them and how are
they paying how are you paying for
school um well my oldest daughter okay
well she took out um
alone unfortunate but the good thing is
that she got was able to apply for a lot
of Pell grants and things good so she
got from seventeen thousand she got it
down to six thousand okay and so we've
got to find six thousand next year so
she doesn't go into any further into
debt exactly between you honor and
that's going to be working her tail off
in the summer right exactly you're not
in school you're not in school you're
working 60 80 hours a week to get ready
to go back exactly set the problem
having with my youngest daughter she's
got she's 18 and she does work she is in
school right now but she kind of like
threw out there the other day
about wanting to leave school somewhat
too not she's not cuz she's still kind
of like deciding what she wants to do so
I said to her but if you're not in
school you will be working a full-time
job
yeah and be leaving shortly exit right
exactly that's about 6 min up within
about 6 months right
originally Rachel would ya you know
Rachel you but you work with these high
school students and these college
students all the time and you're talking
to them kind of from their side of the
coin do you hear anything they're this
mom and I are doing that we need to do
different no I mean what you're saying
is right and the fact that they're still
in school is kind of their paths and a
way to me but but for the 24 year old
Matt I would I'm guessing should be
ending school soon she may have another
year left and so I would even start
working yeah should be done in November
actually ok perfect so I would have an
exit plan I mean already be talking
through okay what does it look like when
you graduate how many more months will
you stay here you know hopefully she'll
find a job and head on out after her
graduation but you know she may we say
up to six months they can stay so around
that time but again I would I would
start talking and over-communicate about
the exit plan especially for the 24 year
old because what happens is it kind of
is getting to have it and they end up
staying there and it just that continues
to be their life and they just stay
until they're 32 or something Christ -
you know the other thing is that sends a
message to the 18 year old that that you
know that school is tied to this free
rent thing and and so it's just good for
them
I mean our oldest daughter we love her
she's an easy person to get along with
she moved back in with us
about three months after school to make
a transition into a new job and to get
into an apartment get a roommates all
lined up and stuff and we were happy she
was there but I promise you within two
months of that kid moving out being
completely on her own paying her own
bills writing her own check for the
electric company doing all of those
kinds of things her maturity her
emotional maturity changed dramatically
within 90 days of her leaving the nest
it's just good for them it's good forces
you to grow up it forces you to be an
adult and to see expenses and to know
that you have to take care of it you're
responsible for things and changes the
whole dynamic and I want to just
reiterate there was no conflict Sharon
and I enjoy having Denise under a roof
we would have loved to have had her stay
there you know just on a personal basis
no on the sense that really well we
never let y'all know that but it didn't
it wasn't like you had to leave because
we were sick of you you know because
you're being a jerk or something some
kids are ready for him to leave so this
kid was you know I was enjoy she's a joy
to be around as I go yes and easy to be
around and there was no troubles nothing
like that but I just the blessing it was
to her to let her stand on her own two
feet was absolutely huge
you